die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den sport an schöne guten andere von
mir großer tag für den sport heute das
olympische feuer brennt tokio eröffnet
die 32 sommerspiele im zeichen der
chorakademie zerstörte gleise verwüstete
bahnhöfe die bahn schätzt die
hochwasserschäden auf 1,3 milliarden
euro
der wiederaufbau könnte jahre dauern und
abschied von alfred biolek mit koch und
talkshows schrieb fernsehgeschichte
nun ist der entertainer im alter von 87
jahren gestorben wir beginnen in tokio
11.000 athletinnen und athleten aus 205
ländern freuen sich dass es nun endlich
offiziell losgeht mit den sommerspielen
mit über einem jahr verspätung
doch zugleich drückt die pandemie die
stimmung trotz aller vorsichtsmaßnahmen
gibt es schon mehr als 100 corona fälle
in den teams die eröffnungszeremonie
heute nachmittag von nahezu ohne
publikum statt nur rund 1000 ehrengäste
waren zugelassen
das motto vereint durch emotionen sollte
ein zeichen der hoffnung setzen
aus tokio berichtet tom pollock
es ist kurz vor mitternacht in tokio als
tennisspielerin der omi usa das
olympische feuer entzündet die nächsten
16 tage wird es brennen während die
athletinnen und athleten um medaillen
kämpfen
zuvor wurde getanzt es wurde gefeiert
tokio schlug eine brücke zwischen
gegenwart und vergangenheit die
eröffnungsshow perfekt inszeniert das
obligatorische feuerwerk inklusive
doch spätestens als die olympischen
teams im stadion einzogen war klar was
fehlt die fans auf den rängen nur
ausgewählte honoratioren und der
japanische kaiser waren anwesend
die angst der deutschen fahnenträger
laura ludwig und patrick hausding über
ihre füße zu stolpern war unbegründet es
lief alles glatt
nachdem alle teams versammelt sind
erklärt kaiser naruhito die 32
inzwischen spiele in tokio für eröffnet
doch auch das gab es heute wieder
proteste gegen olympia mehrere gruppen
insgesamt einige hundert menschen
forderten eine absage der spiele die
olympischen spiele verschlucken nur
gelder und der ioc angefangen mit bach
bereichert sich damit das ist
unverzeihlich
deswegen sind wir dagegen auch während
der show protestierte eine gruppe beim
stadion weiter wurde von der polizei
eingekesselt olympia fans erlebten
währenddessen ein besonderes highlight
800 drohnen schwebten über dem
olympiastadion durch tokios nachdem die
spiele haben begonnen nun wird sich
zeigen ob die skepsis in japan noch
umschlägt in olympische begeisterung
in tokio ist es tiefe nacht dabei jochen
breyer ist für uns wach geblieben
jochen die spiele starten unter
schlechten bedingungen kann sich da
überhaupt noch ein olympischer zauber
entwickeln
ja ich glaube die meisten hier in japan
wären schon froh wenn es kein fauler
zauber wird also wenn ich das eintritt
was viele hier befürchten dass diese
spiele zum super spreading event werden
du hast gesagt barbara mehr als 100
fälle gab es schon im olympia tross und
die infektionszahlen in tokio die
steigen ja auch weiter also ich glaube
vor diesem hintergrund können es gar
keine zauberhaften spiele werden eher
sterile spiele ohne publikum ohne
stimmung so wie heute auch bei der
eröffnungsfeier aber ihren sportlichen
reiz kann diese globale leistungs messe
der welt besten athletinnen und athleten
dann natürlich trotzdem entfalten
dankeschön nach tokio jochen breyer war
das alles zu den olympischen
sommerspielen finden sie auch in der
zdf- heute- app unter unter sportstudio
punkt de dort gibt es zum beispiel bis
zu zehn parallele livestreams exklusiv
online und jetzt zur flutkatastrophe vor
einer stunde setzten die kirchen ein
zeichen
bundesweites glocken läuten zum gedenken
an die opfer in andachten sprachen die
gemeinden ihre solidarität mit den
menschen in den zerstörten regionen aus
die zahl der todesopfer ist auf 179
gestiegen fast 150 menschen werden noch
vermisst
so viele tragödien und menschliches leid
dazu zerstörungen in historischem ausmaß
bei der bahn müssen mindestens 600
kilometer schienen instand gesetzt
werden etwa die jetzt eigentlich kommen
sollten etwa 2000 helfer sind dafür im
einsatz geschätzte kosten mindestens 1,3
milliarden euro ähnliches bild auf der
straße autobahnen sind teils unbefahrbar
viele nebenstrecken wurden einfach
weggespült peter böhme das wasser ist
weg die schäden kommen brutal zum
vorschein
hier kann erstmal kein zug mehr fahren
zerstörte brücken bahnhöfe stellwerke
voll gelaufener aufzüge die schäden sind
massiv und überall heute morgen online
pressekonferenz der bahn mit einer
ersten bilanz fakt ist das kann man ganz
klar sagen dieser dimension wurde in
unsere infrastruktur die auf einen
schlag so zerstört wir stehen hier
wahrlich vor einem gewaltigen kraftakt
in nrw und rheinland pfalz sind mehrere
bahnstrecken mittel bis langfristig
gesperrt der auswahl einer linie wie der
erft heilbaren zwischen euskirchen und
bad münstereifel ist hier auf dem land
schlimm etwa für pendler und schüler
anlagen und gleise von den fluten
zerfleddert die bahn hofft
unser ziel ist es bis jahresende etwa 80
der beschädigten infrastruktur wieder
auf vordermann zu bringen
und natürlich auch deutlich vorher
schrittweise sukzessive dem betrieb
weiterhin aufzunehmen die behörden am
boden bekamen heute unterstützung aus
der luft ein bundeswehr airbus überflog
vier stunden lang die hochwassergebiete
auftrag fotos machen um das ausmaß der
schäden zu dokumentieren
auch auf den straßen stillstand knapp 60
autobahn kilometer auf der a 61 und
einem teil der a1 sind dauerhaft
gesperrt mancherorts wurde die straße
einfach weggerissen
wir hatten insgesamt 40 voll und
teilsperrungen davon sind 35 wieder
aufgehoben
und diese fünf die wir jetzt noch haben
das sind über eure komplexes
schadensbild da werden wir durchaus
länger brauchen wochen und monate die
bahn will nun anders bauen als vorher
brückenpfeiler etwa weiter auseinander
damit sie nicht zum hindernis für
treibgut werden könnten bei der nächsten
flut die fluten der
hochwasserkatastrophe haben
unvorstellbar viel kaputtgemacht häuser
möbel öltanks baumstämme all das stapelt
sich jetzt zu gewaltigen trümmerbergen
wohin mit all dem müll
die entsorger geraten an ihre grenzen
susanne gelhard berichtet in dernau hat
das hochwasser der riesige müllberge
zurückgelassen in giftigem staub und
schlamm versuchen die menschen ihre
häuser frei zu bekommen
es sind schlimmste hygienische
bedingungen 1000 vermittelt durch die
straßen gelaufen ist schleppt oder
keller aus bogen über als in die
ölfirmen zu sehen wir haben gott sei
dank das thw in der nähe und die kümmern
sich jetzt um diesen schlamm und diesen
schmutz damit eben diese
verunreinigungen schnellstmöglichst
behoben werden
die solchen gefahr entgegen zu laufen
der müll muss so schnell es geht weg am
wochenende wird weiterer regen
befürchtet kanäle und flussbetten müssen
so gut es geht frei sein
sperrmüll verseuchter schlamm alles wird
zur verbrennung in zwischenlager
gebracht
also sind im moment natürlich nur
schätzungen die wir sagen können da wir
vermuten mal locker dass in diesen
wenigen tagen schon mehr
zusammengekommen sein wird als
vielleicht sonst in ihrem gesamten jahr
müll und schmutz überall tetanus
impfungen sollen betroffene und helfer
jetzt bei verletzungen schützen sind
mobiles in dem ganz freiwillig gemeldet
nachdem wir von diesen dieser
katastrophe erfahren haben und sind
organisiert glaube ich durch die
bundeswehr
und wir haben jetzt 100 impfdosen dabei
und laufen jetzt durch die straßen und
tetanus impfstoff hilfe die dringend
benötigt wird beim aufräumen und das ist
jetzt das wichtigste
es ist weiter viel hilfe nötig bei der
zdf spendenaktion sind bereits mehr als
40 millionen euro zusammengekommen
dieses spendenkonto hat das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
eingerichtet die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
hochwasser weitere informationen finden
sie unter spenden punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 kommen wir zu
krone und den zahlen hier geht der trend
weiter nach oben seit zwei wochen steigt
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
kontinuierlich an
aktuell liegt sie bei 13,2 ein blick in
die statistik zeigt vor allem jüngere
stecken sich an in der gruppe der 15 bis
24 jährigen ist die inzidenz mit 32 am
höchsten
zum vergleich bei menschen über 60 liegt
sie bei knapp 5 sehr viel ernster ist
die situation in den niederlanden und in
spanien
dort explodieren die zahlen förmlich
incidence über 300 auf mallorca liegt
sie bei 365
die bundesregierung setzt deshalb beide
länder ab dienstag auf die liste der
hoch incidents gebiet
für urlauber heißt das wer nicht genesen
oder vollständig geimpft ist muss nach
der rückkehr mindestens fünf tage in
quarantäne
erst dann kann man sich frei testen das
trifft vor allem familien mit kindern
auch für unter 12-jährige gelten die
quarantäne regeln deutschlands apotheken
können ab nächster woche nach und nach
wieder im zertifikate ausstellen der
zugang zum portal des deutschen
apothekerverbands werde schrittweise
freigeschaltet so das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
wegen einer sicherheitslücke war die
ausstellung gestern gestoppt worden und
kinder und jugendliche ab zwölf können
künftig auch den corona impfstoff von
moderner bekommen die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema hat grünes licht
gegeben
die eu kommission muss noch zustimmen
was als formsache gilt
bislang wird bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen
nur der impfstoff von bayern tag
verwendet in afrika ist an das impfen
von jugendlichen überhaupt nicht zu
denken es gibt kaum impfstoff gegen
korona aktuell sind gerade mal 1,5
prozent der menschen auf dem kontinent
geimpft
wohl auch deswegen schnellen die
todesfälle im zusammenhang mit dem virus
nach oben zuletzt um mehr als 40 prozent
besonders dramatisch ist die lage in
tunesien das land hat die höchste
sterblichkeit in der region
thomas walde berichtet
ein krankenhaus in tunis die räume
überfüllt mit co wird patienten manche
muss auf dem boden sitzen weil es keine
betten mehr gibt das personal sagt es
fehle an allem
hier haben die vier patienten die an
eine sauerstoff quelle angeschlossen
sind sauerstoff fehlt uns total wir
fühlen uns allein in einem krieg wir
sind auf uns an einigen stellen mitten
unter den patienten ein mann der den
kampf gegen chur wird verloren hat wir
haben keinen platz um patienten
aufzunehmen wir warten dass jemand
stirbt um platz zu bekommen für den
nächsten patienten die lage ist
katastrophal
tunesien hat die höchste
sterblichkeitsrate durch ko wird auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent gerade mal etwas
mehr als jeder zehnte ist geimpft
es klappt nicht wie viele sind wir 12
millionen tunesier die amerikaner haben
schon alle geimpft nach einem jahr wird
haben wir nicht genug gehen
einer der vor kurzem seine erste impfung
erhielt ist der präsident des landes wir
verlieren den krieg gegen co wird nicht
wir verlieren ihn nicht wir führen ihn
mit unseren mitteln unserem willen und
unseren fähigkeiten die armee tunesiens
hilft nun beim impfen frankreich und
china haben zugesagt impfstoff zu
schicken
nach thüringen im landtag in erfurt ist
ein misstrauensvotum gegen
ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
gescheitert es war von der afg initiiert
worden
dafür hatte sie ihren vorsitzenden bernd
hocke zur wahl gestellt doch er bekam
keine mehrheit sondern nur 22 stimmen so
viele wie seine partei sitze hat die cdu
fraktion nahm nicht an der abstimmung
teil alle anderen stimmten mit nein
bodo ramelow von den linken führt seit
letztem jahr eine rot rot grüne
minderheitsregierung fragen wir melanie
haack unsere korrespondentin in
thüringen warum hat sich die cdu nicht
an der abstimmung beteiligt ja offiziell
heißt es aus der cdu man wolle bei
diesem schmierentheater der afg nicht
mitmachen aber im grunde ging es ihr
wohl darum dass mögliche stimme nicht
ihr zugeschrieben werden denn es war ja
eine geheime wahl und hätte björn höcke
mehr stimmen bekommen als seine fraktion
mandate hat dann wäre die frage gewesen
woher diese stimmen kommen und das wäre
sicherlich zu schuldzuweisungen gekommen
und dann auch in richtung cdu
deshalb haben sie entschieden bei der
abstimmung sitzen zu bleiben das
wiederum hat für viel empörung und
diskussionen gesorgt auch von rot und
rot grün weil die cdu sich eben nicht
klar positioniert hat mit einem nein zu
be on hocker wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter im landtag nach der sommerpause
ja das ist eine gute frage die sich hier
auch alle beteiligten stellen das
parlament geht in die sommerpause und
ist gleichzeitig wahnsinnig zerstritten
viel vertrauen es in den letzten wochen
verloren gegangen auch im rahmen der
verhandlungen um die neuwahlen die
zuletzt abgesagt wurden und hinzu kommt
die minderheitsregierung unter bodo
ramelow wird ab jetzt nicht mehr
gestützt von der cdu dieser sogenannte
stabilitätspakt wurde aufgekündigt das
heißt sie müssen künftig mehrheiten
finden in diesem parlament dass eben
gerade wahnsinnig mit sich selbst
beschäftigt ist und dann ist die frage
im herbst wie sie das umsetzen wollen
vor allem dann auch wenn wichtige
entscheidungen wie der haushalt fürs
nächste jahr anstehen danke melanie
haack nach erfurt
zu einem der ganz großen unserer branche
alfred biolek er setzte maßstäbe mit
seinen shows und mit seiner
freundlichkeit kaum jemand konnte so
klug und humorvoll plaudern
angst vor dem tod habe er nicht sagte er
mal über 100 werden wolle er auch nicht
mit 87 ist er heute in köln friedlich
eingeschlafen so erzählt es sein
adoptivsohn anja klingen erinnert alfred
biolek talkmaster und fernsehkoch drei
jahrzehnte war er aus dem deutschen
fernsehen nicht wegzudenken
seine karriere begann beim zdf ganz
seriös in der rechtsabteilung aus seiner
vorliebe für gutes essen und guten wein
entsteht die sendung alfried desimo
gepflegte kommunikation mit prominenten
gewürzt mit humor und sicher sonst nicht
eben schauen sie da muss ich sagen ist
mir der liebe als dieser politischen amt
mit zwei älteren brüdern erlebt alfred
biolek eine unbeschwerte kindheit in
böhmen erst als student beginnt er zu
realisieren dass er männer liebt das hat
man verdrängt
man hat nicht einmal mit sich selbst
darüber gesprochen geschweige denn mit
irgendwelchen anderen die shows bios
bahnhof und boulevard bio werden kult
humorige aber respektvolle gespräche
aller bio mit der prominenz mit 73
verabschiedet sich das multitalent vom
fernsehen
2008 erhält er die goldene kamera für
sein lebenswerk mit 84 dann bringt
biolek ein kochbuch heraus die rezepte
meines lebens so etwas wie sein
vermächtnis bleibt auf jeden fall auch
wenn ich nicht mehr bin für mich ist es
nicht so unangenehm es daran zu denken
dass irgendwann der tod kommt
nicht hadern sondern demütig und dankbar
sein
biolek hat das leben die bühne und sein
publikum geliebt ja wir ihn auch nutzen
die eröffnungsfeier in tokio hatten wir
schon man es gab auch schon erste
wettkämpfe im ruder da haben aber nur
zwei deutsche boote wirklich überzeugt
der doppelvierer der frauen der gewann
den vorlauf und zog direkt ins finale
ein und ruderweltmeister und einer
dominator oliver zeidler der kam
souverän ins viertelfinale
kurz vor dem ziel konnte oliver zeidler
sogar noch kraft sparen
sieben minuten hatte für die 2000 meter
getaucht ein guter auftakt im rennen
natürlich besser wird vorlaufsieger
zeitler gilt als große goldhoffnung
dabei war der ehemalige schwimmer erst
2016 ins boot gewechselt tokio ist seine
olympia-premiere morgenfeier zeitler
seinen 25 geburtstag viel zeit zum
feiern bleibt ihm nicht wetterbedingt
wird sein viertelfinale nicht am montag
sondern bereits am sonntag ausgetragen
erster corona fall im deutschen
olympia-team radsportler simon geschke
ist positiv auf das virus getestet
worden und wird deshalb nicht am
morgigen straßen rennen teilnehmen
seit dem ersten juli sind dem umfeld der
spiele 110 personen darunter 13 athleten
positiv auf das virus getestet worden
der dfb pokal spiele im free tv
die ard und jetzt auch wieder das zdf
dürfen von der saison 2022/23 bis 2025
26 pro spielzeit 15 partien live
übertragen zwei mehr als bisher
auch die clip verwertung im internet
gehört zu den erworbenen rechten
ja der fußball rollt wieder hierzulande
saisonstart der zweiten bundesliga heute
abend das eröffnung spielt da treffen
zwei traditionsklubs aufeinander
die einzige gemeinsam haben den
wiederaufstieg schaffen schalke und der
hsv timm walter ist mittlerweile der
sechste trainer der versuch den hsv
zurück zu bringen nach drei zweitliga
jahren sein ansatz ein neuer wir
versuchen eine neue identität was was
das ganze spiel anbelangt zu aufzuzeigen
und ich glaube dass immer auf einem
guten weg direkt zurück wollen die
schalker natürlich und haben dafür den
torjäger geholt der letzte saison 24 mal
für die hamburger getroffen hatte simon
terodde gebliebenes trainer gramm hat es
ein neubeginn mit dem der den abstieg
letztlich nicht mehr hatte verhindern
können dass hatte auch der hsv vor drei
jahren zunächst so versucht und das
war's vom sport dankeschön können
vorsicht beim wetter morgen früh ziehen
die ersten gewitter im südwesten auf die
sich weiter nach norden und osten
ausbreiten mehr dazu gleich von katja
honnefer sie ist auch bei christian
sievers im heute journal um 10
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
guten abend die dichten wolken an der
nordsee sorgten dafür dass es hier auf
sylt nur 18 grad gab
ganz anders sah es dagegen am oberrhein
aus da kletterten die wir den bis 30
grad und am oberrhein wird es dann auch
in der nacht am mildesten bleiben da
sinken die werte auf 16 grad genauso wie
in der lausitz in der lüneburger heide
geht es bis neun grad runter und schon
in der nacht kommen dichtere wolken von
frankreich heran da könnte es im
schwarzwald schon für den ersten
regenschauer reichen
morgen am vormittag sind dann schon die
ersten gewitter unterwegs im saarland
und in rheinland pfalz sonst geht er
vormittag noch sehr sonnig los aber die
gewitter breiten sich aus erreichen bis
zum abend das südliche niedersachsen
nordrhein-westfalen hessen vielleicht
sogar thüringen und bayern
die gewitter schwerpunkte finden sich
wohl im südlichen rheinland pfalz und
den bayern das können unwetter seien
gewitter die mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen verbunden sind bis zu 30 liter
regen pro quadratmeter in einer stunde
sind durchaus möglich
die temperaturen morgen liegen zwischen
23 und 30 grad und auch am sonntag geht
es sehr gewittrig weiter die sonne
werden sie aber zwischendurch auch mal
sehen können und die gewitter begleitet
uns auch noch montag und dienstag am
mittwoch ist es dann deutlich
freundlicher guten abend